تقرير للمنتدى التونسي للحقوق الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه كشف عن فقدان
608 مهاجرين في السته اشهر الماضيه اثناء
محاولتهم امورا المتوسط الى السواحل
الايطاليه شهر ابريل الماضي سجل وحده
فقدان
373 من جنسيات مختلفه التقرير اعلن وصول
اكثر من الف مهاجر الى الضفه الاوروبيه
كاعلى حصيده لموجات الهجره غير النظاميه
من السواحل التونسيه في شهر مايو الماضي
واظهرت الارقام ان عدد القاصرين التونسيين
الذين وصلوا الى السواحل الايطاليه خلال
الاشهر السته الاولى من العام الجاري بلغ
الفا واربعه واربعين قصيرا بينما وصلت
282 مهاجره تونسيه الى السواحل الايطاليه
واكثر من 32,000 شخص احبطت محاولاتهم
للهجره مسار الهجره بين تونس واوروبا
الاخطر في العالم
حيث لقي اكثر من عشرين الف شخص حتفهم
اثناء محاولتهم عبوره منذ العام 2014
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات